الناس انصدمت انه شو وصلك لفوق انت بالاخر
يعني هذا محل اللي بشكل عام مش مؤهل
للحياه مش مؤهل الواحد يوصلوا كيف وصلت
لفوق
[موسيقى]
هي القمه مش كثير محبوبه عند متسلقين
الجبال لانها ما فيها كثير محلات تامني
حالك فيها يعني لازم الواحد يروح جاهز
نفسيا وجايز من ناحيه خبره حتى مشان يكون
قادر انه يطلع الكلمه ما فيها قلق ولا اي
منطقه يعني حلقات حديديه بتكون كل 30 او
40 متر فواحد من التحديات كانت انه احنا
نتصل لك الكميب وسائلنا الخاصه
[موسيقى]
مسار عاده بده بين ثلاث لاربع ساعات بس
اخذ منا وقت اكثر بدي السبب انه كثير
محلاتكن نوقف فيهم مش عارفين كيف نكمل كنا
نفكر كثير وين ممكن نامن حالنا باي صخره
ومش كل الصخور طبعا بتكون صخور ثابته
فبدنا نفحص اذا الصخره بتكون ثابته مشان
الامن حالنا فيها وما يصير اي اشي اي
اشكاليه بحاله واحد منا سمح الله
طبعا الناس كانت مصدومه انا حتى انا كنت
مصدوم لما شفت الفيديوهات اللي صورتها
بالدرون ما كنتش متخيل كيف الاشي بكون
يعني احنا بنشوف اشي من زاويه لما نتصلى
وبعدين لما انا بروح بشوف الاشي من زاويه
ثانيه حسب الاشياء اللي صورتها فلما شفت
الاشي قديش هو حاد فهمت رده فعل الناس
اللي كانت صادمه طبعا بس يعني بالنهايه هو
نوع الرياضه هي مش انتحار ولا مخاطره هي
نوع الرياضه بيحتاج لممارسه بيحتاج لتدريب
محتاج لتمرين كثير مش واحد يوصلك مناطق
وبحاله الواحد كان متمرس وكان عنده الخبره
الكافيه فش ولا اي مشكله انه يوصل اي محل